mécanicien de formation bruno marchand
ne travaillait plus depuis cinq ans le
corps trop abîmées par le travail en vie
une entreprise de réinsertion implantée
à trappes lui a permis de retrouver un
emploi pour cinq mois et de se former à
un autre métier on essaye les machines
avancent à vendre tout et verte on les
démonte tout annuler
c'est une chance très bien plus
longtemps ah ouais très bien
l'association reçoit chaque jour 4 à 5
tonnes de matériel électroménager de
fournisseurs un tri opéré entre les
appareils réparable ou non avant qu'il
soit révisé pour être mise en vente
autant de postes de travail qui offre
une seconde chance cheikh camara arrivé
en juillet espère déjà être prolongé
c'est d'un contrat pour les personnes
qui seraient plus de cinq mois ou six
mois au chômage comment donc là ça
permet de se relancer dans le domaine
professionnel de l'emploi les processus
voilà voilà par la suite évolué grâce à
l'association en vie onze personnes ont
obtenu un contrat d'insertion
professionnelle mais cela ne doit pas
s'arrêter là notre objectif avec le
suffit que l'on fait c'est de pouvoir
leur offrir et les aider dans leur
démarche a trouvé un cdi
voir un cdd de plus de six mois ou une
formation qualifiante envie réinsère
dans le monde du travail mais offre
aussi des appareils à moitié prix par
rapport aux produits neufs vendus en
magasin et avec une garantie d'un an
face aux demandes des futurs clients la
partie magasin est déjà mise en place
dans la zone industrielle de trappes
elancourt mais l'ouverture officielle
est prévue pour le 6 octobre